hi everyone it's jerry this is game
eight from the 2014 world chess
championship match between magnus
carlson and vichy nund
going into this game carlson has a 4-3
lead over and on
and on with the white pieces in this one
he opened with
d4 he has yet to change it up starting
all games with the d4
and we follow game three
this game eight here
we follow game three all the way up to
move
six
and move six in game three we had knight
b to d7 but in this game eight we now
have
c5 creating some more central tension
and whenever i have or whenever i see
this type of tension between the c and d
pawns
i'm immediately drawn to certain
structures thinking about
capturing and then capturing here that
would be a way to saddle black with an
isolated d-pawn
and also
this here if white is to make some move
black has the option of saddling white
with an isolated d-pawn in this game
here
neither occur
neither side is saddled with an isolated
queen pun
these guys are all exchanged and the c
and d files are completely opened
what follows is move 7 d take c bishop
takes
and now this tension will remain for
some time
black does not want to take on the c4
square
until this bishop has moved
and
well this bishop doesn't want to move so
fast white wants to make some more
useful moves keeping this
tension in the position
a3 first there might be an idea of
expanding on the queen side with b4 this
will also watch out for any knight hop
into the b4 square
we'll see how this is useful after
knight c6 we have queen c2
the queen is much more secure now on
this post
rook to e8 preparing to have the rook
activated should white go ahead and
follow through with this capture the
rook is brought
right to life so
white will not be so quick to make this
capture
instead
bishop to g5 moving the same piece twice
i guess we could say uh
one of the chess principles has been
violated with that move but is that
really so significant in this position
i'm not so sure
the idea with this is to indirectly
put some pressure on the d5 pawn two
pieces are hitting it
this knight is no longer going to be
around
to lend support to d5 and what's right
around the corner is additional pressure
on the d5 pawn as well
now in this game we had the bishop g5
move this pinning move
simply broken
immediately with bishop e7
another try
could have been d4
and after d4 there could be queen side
castle
e5
knight d5 bishop back we could have this
line here where at the end of it
we have white being up a pawn but black
is very very active hitting the rook
hitting the bishop
the short story in this
position here is that while white is up
upon
black will have very active pieces as an
example the bishop on b7 is excellent
the queen is very well placed and if we
do a king comparison
the black king
is
more secure
we can expect rook to c8 white will need
some time to bring the king over here so
while up while white is up a pawn in
this variation
black has really well placed pieces and
a safer king
this is not a direction we went in this
was an option however to play d4 but
instead it was the much more calm
reserved approach to simply break the
pin
and we have a similar situation going on
with the next move after white's
rook to d1 pinning the pawn black is
quick to get out of that pin as well
with queen a5
bishop to d3
and now h6
there was a threat here to take the
knight
and then grab that pawn with check so h6
is quite convenient
getting that move back
throwing a punch at the bishop meeting
the threat on h7 he has to react backs
up to h4
notice
well if you capture the knight you're
giving up the bishop pair and the
alternative square of going to f4
that does run into e5
black can't expand it doesn't seem
initially
at least that the e5 pawn is protected
enough but it is because we have this
idea here where d take c throws a punch
at
both bishops
so the better reaction is bishop h4 the
move played in the game
now d takes c bishop takes
and a6 black simply needs to get this
bishop
developed
a6 is a step in that direction looking
to play b5
with tempo and then bishop to b7
castles
b5 is in bishop to a2
during the live stream of this
when i was live streaming this game i
had questioned what are some differences
between these two squares for one if
he's going to b3 instead of the move
played in the game a2
you'll notice he's more accessible to a
knight let's say at some stage
and when he's on a2
he has other ideas in mind
namely to come to this diagonal
something we do so
something we do see show up in this game
after bishop b7
it's bishop to b1
looking to eliminate the knight and
enter
on h7
and black's reply
is to simply contest the open file
there isn't much fear
of this h7 square it may appear
a bit scary but it really isn't
after rook on a to d8
we have in fact bishop takes knight
bishop takes bishop
and not queen to h7 instead knight e4
why was queen h7 not played let's have a
look at this
queen h7 king f8
if another check is thrown in well the
king is perfectly tucked in
on e7
throws a punch right back at the queen
there really wouldn't be much
point in playing to the h8 square at
least at this stage
and
i think she's really just out of play
the bishop is an excellent defender of
the black king side structure and again
this is a wonderful home perfectly good
home on e7
if the queen gives the check and king f8
is played what can be tried is knight e4
and this bishop
seems like he could grab this pawn but
there would be no
knight to d6 and this indeed would be
uncomfortable for the black side knight
d6 hits the bishop hits the rook
if you don't move the rook you're going
to lose the rook
and
if you do move the rook well now
of course this is effective that's a
mate so what black could do if we did
have this variation with queen check
king f8 and now knight e4
there is the simple rook takes on d
rook takes rook
and now rook to d8 there is no knight
takes bishop with check here
the rook is unprotected white needs to
do something about that on rook takes
rook there is queen takes
and a knight takes bishop
well that would actually drop mate
so
this would be a way in other words
to meet this ensuing knight to e4 move
to play
simply rook takes rook rook takes rook
and rook to d8
and rook takes rook queen takes and now
we would have basically the queens come
off
knight takes and it's a completely equal
position
knight takes bishop
king takes we're tending towards a draw
in that line
this was not played in the game
instead 94 directly
hitting the bishop
and looking at that c5 square is a very
important square i've highlighted many
times a white knight getting to f5
that is very inconvenient to
the black king side of the board
this f5 square is inconvenient to the
king side of the board and with regard
to the queen side of the board the one
square that is inconvenient to the black
side
is c5 and that's where the knight is
heading
bishop is there to control that square
and now as soon as the knight moves he
needs to go
he's hitting the bishop and
the main threat
is that this is a main two threat the
bishop needs to move so that the king
can quickly run to e7
the knight is gone
queen recaptures she's the one piece in
the white or she's the one piece in the
black position
and black is quick to get rid of her
with b4 offering a queen exchange
rook c1
b takes a
b takes a queen takes queen something
other than this rook to c1 move
suppose queen takes queen
knight takes queen was played
and then a takes b
there can follow knight c6 i believe
that this would be fine
and another one is
knight to c4
putting some pressure on the b2 pawn
if b3 is played
there can follow bishop takes f3
this is a little bit complicated but at
the end this knight is very active
g takes f3 and knight to d2
this would be a way to get that pawn
back
but we don't have that
instead it is rook c1 at this stage
b takes a b takes a the queens are off
this is the new piece that's in the
black position and so black addresses
that
the knight e7
looking to contest the rook with rook c8
white doubles
c5 rook is challenged
a lot of exchanges here it's quite
typical when there are a few
well there are three open files in this
case but
it's likely in this in this position
that both sets of rooks
are exchanged and they they are indeed
exchanged in this one after bishop d3
that's just a slight improvement
of the bishop's position
rook to
d8 both sets of rooks are exchanged the
knight recaptures and now
the one concern
on the black side is a knight yet again
trying to arrive on the c5 square
we have first knight d2
not getting the kings involved just yet
there is this small battle going on
between the knights with these next few
moves
the white knight looking to get to c5
and
be all the more appealing since it comes
with tempo on the bishop
and adds an additional
threat or an additional attacker against
the a6 pawn
but black is there with knight b6 and a
knight b3 knight d7 just in time
to make sure
that great square is watched over by the
black knight
now
is the time
to get the kings working after
knight a5 bishop back the kings get
rolling
towards the center
we have a knight move inserted the
bishop simply tucks back here
restricting the knight
king c5 this is a strong
well it appears that it's a strong king
position but he can be kick to back
knight b3 is one way to do it
and well we see another approach as well
the move played in the game here f4
kicks the knight back to c6
the knights are now exchanged this
position has simplified quite a bit
no longer nights around no longer so
much calculation needed
king position immediately if any player
is the preferred side here it is white
king d4 f6
and
the try here for black is to try and get
a quick king d6 and then
e5 in
but white is not going to allow that
first it's e4 and on king d6 e5
this pawn
is now going to be fixed on this light
square and is a potential target one day
for the bishop
however after this move e5 it is at this
point that both players
agree to a drop having this pawn fixed
on a light square will not be
enough to press for a win in this
position
the players again agree to a drop this
point after this e5 advance
on f takes e f takes e king c6 notice
how these squares are covered
and
the black king will be responsible for
covering the dark square he can always
move back and forth here
there if there's a check thrown in king
here let's say that white keeps their
pawns on all these dark squares
how exactly to make progress
even if the bishop comes back to this
point
this guy could just go back and forth
and again this there's this giant wall
here
where exactly does this king make
progress and put himself in a position
to even attack
any of the black pawns how do you get at
this base point for example there's just
not a way to make progress in this final
position here having one pawn fixed on a
light square
as a potential target for this guy is
just not going to be
enough to press for some type of a win
so
after this again the players agree to
draw and this gets pushed to game nine
of course tomorrow is a rest day
the point system or the point total for
both sides at this stage is carlson four
and a half and a nand three and a half
again we are racing to six and a half
to determine a champion
so we'll see what happens in game nine
and as always i hope you got something
out of this video take care bye
you